russia now claims to control 97 percent
of one of the two provinces that make up
the region in the east of the country
and it says its forces have taken full
control of residential areas in that key
city of several donetsk that's where we
have had reports of troops fighting
street by street
ukraine admitting its forces now are
outnumbered but it says seeding
territory to russia is not an option
inflicting maximum damage
that is the goal for moscow which
released this footage of its howitzers
at work
across ukraine's east
the destruction is evident
many of those who remain have lost
everything
i do not even know where to start
i am standing here and looking
but i have no idea what to do
i start crying i calm down then i cry
again and again
the focus now is on the city of seville
donetsk which could be key to gain
control of the donbass
[Music]
ukraine says its troops are outnumbered
but holding strong
our heroes are not giving up their
positions in seville donetsk
fierce street fights continue in the
city
the russian army is trying to deploy
additional forces in the donbas
direction
but it's the 103rd day
and the ukrainian dunba stands it stands
firmly
the cost of that resistance has been
high
even as russia threatens dire
consequences to more help from the west
ukraine says that for its embattled
troops
more weapons could be the difference
between life and death
and now to those fears of a growing
global food crisis millions of tons of
grain are piling up in southern ukraine
going nowhere because the war has
blocked ships from leaving ports today
addressing the u.n security council in
new york european council president
charles michelle he put the blame
squarely on russia take a listen
russia
is solely responsible for this food
crisis russia alone
despite the kremlin's campaign of lies
and disinformation
i've seen it with my own eyes a few
weeks ago in odessa
millions of tons of grain and wheat
stuck in containers and ships
because
of russian warships in the black sea
and because our freshest attack on
transport infrastructure
and it is russian tents
russian bumps and mines that are
preventing ukraine from planting and
harvesting
the kremlin is also targeting grain
storages
and stealing grain in ukraine while
shifting the blame on others
this is currently this is propaganda
pure and simple propaganda
all right let's go now to our
correspondent nick connolly he is in
odessa
in ukraine forest tonight nick it's good
to see you we just heard right there
scathing criticism from the european
council president blaming russia for
this looming global food crisis russia
says it's not responsible it's blaming
ukraine saying the ukrainian military
needs to demine the waters around its
black sea ports before any ships can
leave
is there any solution
to this obvious impasse in sight
i think there's a lot of diplomatic
noise going on right now there's a
meeting tomorrow in turkey between
ministers from russia and turkey with
the un on board and ukrainians somehow
involved we don't quite know how but i
think this is more about the blame game
right now this is not about real
solutions otherwise russia would not
have destroyed ukraine's second biggest
grain terminal just a few days ago in
the city of mikolai
about 150 kilometers down the road from
where i am now the infrastructure on the
ground that could really then let that
food out in a hurry to the people who
need it in north africa in the middle
east that is being destroyed bit by bit
by the russians who are also obviously
making it very hard for ukrainian
farmers to get the diesel they need
they've been bombing oil refineries
bombing oil storage units and roads
and i think now that russia is just
noticing that this is a topic that is
getting a lot of traction
internationally also in countries in
africa and middle east that
traditionally are a lot more sympathetic
to russian narratives than is the case
in europe and north america and seeing
that concern they're now trying to claim
the game place the game on ukraine that
has very little reason to trust russian
guarantees that if it takes the mines
away from odessa's coastline to
protecting odessa from
russian operations right now that that
will be respected and that it won't be
used by russia to come here to invade
the city
i want to talk about where you are right
now nick odessa we know that that city
was the target of heavy russian attacks
in the early days of this war what's it
like there now
well it's kind of
schizophrenic feeling on one hand you
have people out in bars and restaurants
late into the night the curfew has been
pushed back till 11 pm but those are
mainly locals in this city that apart
from its port lives from tourism and
those tourists obviously
nowhere to be seen foreign tourists even
lesser but even people inside ukraine in
the fourth month of war their savings
are running low and they can't think
about affording a holiday so you really
notice that people's uh basically their
reserves their savings are running low
the people are trying to kind of get to
some kind of normality to enjoy this
summer but uh that they are nervous that
they can't really let go because they
don't know what's coming they don't know
if they'll be able to earn a living and
that is a problem that is facing ukraine
now even in parts of the country that
are safe from russian attacks people
don't know if their jobs will still be
there in a week or a month time and
whether they might have to soon leave
for economic reasons rather than
security ones and nick there are some
worrying reports tonight coming out
talking about another key port city the
city of mario poll which is now
controlled by russian forces what can
you tell us
well we've seen reports in ukraine media
about cholera being discovered among
people living in maripod those are as
yet unconfirmed reports we've simply had
reports in the same independent russian
media that some of the border regions of
russia close to mario paul are now
preparing inventories infectious
diseases uh wards for people coming from
there one thing is certain maripole is a
city of ruins people there have very
little access to sanitation um the
occasional water truck going around but
we've seen people washing themselves in
their clothes in the sea um obviously
lots of bodies still unrecovered so it's
a very dangerous situation in the summer
and summer temperatures come in i think
the risk of disease and people suffering
in the ruins of city is just going to
grow yeah the the summer heat is only
going to make things worse that's for
sure nick connolly reporting tonight
from odessa nick as always thank you
[Music]
german chancellor olaf schultz he says
that his government is ready to boost
its military mission in lithuania on a
visit today to vilnius he also met with
the leaders of the other two baltic
countries latvia and estonia given their
proximity to russia they've been calling
for increased nato support to deter and
defend against any aggression from
moscow
cooperation this is what german
chancellor olaf schultz and lithuanian
president guitarist nozeda wanted to
convey the two announced preparations
for an expansion of the multinational
nato combat unit currently stationed in
lithuania and olaf schultz was keen to
shut down criticism regarding germany's
support to ukraine
we will continue supporting ukraine with
weapons deliveries
germany has been doing this more
intensely than almost anybody else and
will continue its support in the near
term
as long as will be needed to rebuff
russian aggression
but words are not enough for both
ukraine and nato allies which pressed
berlin to step up its military support
with the baltic heads of state stressing
their determination to stop russia's
aggression against ukraine
i believe that our colleagues always
have the right to try all the options
they want to try
but this is not lithuania's position
we think it is difficult to talk to a
head of state who is redrawing the
borders in the 21st century
tuesday's meeting was intended to show
unity among nato allies but germany's
support will likely be judged by the
weapons and boots on the ground it
actually provides
both to ukraine and to its nato allies